IMG to kick off
to Bishop Sycamore.
Do you want my hands
like this,
like this, like that?
Just be natural.
You don't have to try.
Coach Roy Johnson
told us
they had a number of
division one prospects.
New high. Tip. Intercepted!
Thanks to the pick six.
Into the end zone.
He'll waltz in.
And that will do it.
Do I look like a con artist?
How this happens
got a lot of people
scratching their head.
Bishop Sycamore is not even
a real high school.
They did not have teachers.
We really was pretty much
on our own.
We didn't have
any trainers.
People were sharing
helmets.
It was disgusting.
I was literally
sick to my stomach.
I can't believe
this happened again.
My philosophy
of business is,
do what the people
who have the money do,
even if you
don't have the money.
Roy will tell you
he's a liar.
He knew what to say,
how to say it.
He's like, "Aw, man,
you gotta let that go."
I said, "I'mma tell you what
I'm gonna let go.
I'm gonna let go of his neck
after I grab it."
I think I'm the most honest
liar that I know.
How can you coach kids,
and you know
it's not a school?
Roy would tell people,
"You're gonna be playing
at Alabama."
He would just sell them
their dream.
Ohio was embarrassed
by this.
They called the thing
explicitly a scam.
And then said they couldn't
do a damn thing about it.
Bishop Sycamore
does not happen
if there wasn't an abundance
of money
in high school sports.
Let's go!
Did I break a law?
Is it illegal? Am I in jail?
We're on ESPN.
Win, lose, or draw, we win.
This is not what
we was supposed to create.
How do I tell my mama
that coach wants me to do
the same stuff
that you tried
to get me away from?
You say you care about us,
but did you really?
Can we take a break?
That's some bull--
-One! Two! Three!
-Hard work!